[Music]
on July 6 2022 a bomb detonated on a
five-acre plot of Farmland in Elberton
Georgia the explosion destroyed a large
Monument that stood on the property for
over 40 years known as the Georgia
Guidestones it was four monolithic slabs
of granite weighing over 230 thousand
pounds that contained a set of rules for
a more peaceful and orderly Society the
identity of the Builder was a mystery
for 40 years but today I'll tell you who
he was but why did he want to keep his
identity a secret probably for the same
reason the Georgia Guidestones were
destroyed because according to the
Guidestones the way to a perfect Society
is through a One World Government
genetic and racial Purity and massive
Global depopulation in other words a new
world order
foreign
June 1979 A well-dressed man using the
pseudonym Robert C Christian approached
Joe Finley president of Elberton Granite
Finishing Company RC Christian wanted to
build a monument to rival the magnitude
and awe of Stonehenge RC Christian had
recently visited Stonehenge and was
impressed though he felt it was missing
something a message but what kind of
message the reason RC Christian used
that name is that he was a Christian
there's no more famous Christian message
than the Ten Commandments and religious
or not the Ten Commandments have rules
that all of us should follow don't lie
don't steal don't hurt anybody but those
are rules for an individual RC Christian
was thinking bigger what bigoted in word
of God give it to Moses from the top of
a mountain yep the eagle in this guy R.C
Christian said he represented a small
group of loyal Americans who had spent
the past 20 years planning an unusually
large and complex Monument he brought
with him a scale model with some very
detailed specifications the structure
would stand 16 feet tall and consist of
four Stones arranged in the shape of a
cross capped with a central Stone the
monument would need to display its
message in the eight most spoken
languages in the world English Spanish
Russian Chinese Arabic Hebrew Hindi and
Swahili it would also show the message
in four dead languages Babylonian
cuneiform Egyptian hieroglyphics
Sanskrit and classical Greek Joe Finley
wasn't taking any of this seriously but
when RC Christian began to describe the
monument Finley stopped what he was
doing Not only was this out of town or
asking for Stones larger than any Fenley
had ever quarried he wanted them cut
polished and arranged as an enormous
astronomical instrument
the fourth standing Stone should outline
the migration of the Moon over a year a
small viewing hole in the middle support
Stone would need to always show the
North Star a slot at the top of the
middle support Stone should align with a
winter and summer solstice's Rising Sun
and indicate noon at the equinoxes a
hole should be drilled through the
Capstone that focuses the sun on the
center column at noon to indicate the
day of the year R.C Christian had won
final request that caused a few people
to question the purpose of the Georgia
guidestone project the stone should be
made to withstand the end of the world
RC Christian now had Joe Finley's full
attention Finley's Granite Company
mostly dealt in wholesale orders for
statues monuments and Tombstone
retailers he had never had a request
like this Bentley's first thought was
this guy's crazy how can I get him out
of here Bentley tried to discourage The
Stranger by quoting him a price much
higher than any job he'd ever worked on
he said the job would need heavy
equipment special tools and expensive
Consultants RC Christian just nodded and
asked how long Bentley wasn't sure how
long it would take six months maybe more
but he wouldn't even consider the job
unless he knew RC Christian had the
money Christian asked if there was a
trustworthy Banker in town well there's
a problem there's no such thing as a
trustworthy Banker well that's a good
point but still Fenley sent RC Christian
to the Granite City Bank and told him to
ask for the bank president Wyatt Martin
at the bank Martin and Christian came to
an agreement Martin would help set up
the bank account where funds could be
transferred to pay for the Guidestones
but the account couldn't be set up under
a false name our RC Christian understood
and agreed to give Martin his real name
but only if he promised to never tell
anyone who he really was or who he
represented no but we know right we do
we're getting there you're fine but
don't take too long the suspense is
giving me adjective Wyatt Martin agreed
and would be the only man to ever know
RC Christian's true identity despite
being hounded for years about this
Martin kept his word to his dying day so
RC Christian transferred the funds
purchased five acres of land in Elbert
County Georgia and construction finally
began and just like that RC Christian
was gone and nobody would ever see him
again
[Music]
the five-acre plot of pasture was the
highest point in Elbert County and
visible from all directions the ideal
location the Georgia Guidestones were
erected and revealed to the public on
March 22nd 1980 the vernal equinox what
it was erected don't don't be a child oh
so in 1980 they revealed their erection
to the public
please don't
okay okay okay you know I couldn't let
that go go ahead I'll behave
a few hundred people local media and
even alberton's Congressman came out for
the unveiling each of the outer slabs
was 16 feet high six feet wide and 19
inches thick the Capstone measured
almost 10 feet long six feet wide and 19
inches thick including the foundation
Stones The Monument's total weight was
almost 240 000 pounds wow that is a big
erection
what it is it is hot as a rack enough
I'm choking I gotta pee oh well
okay go ahead
over the years thousands of visitors
from all over the world would come to
see the Georgia Guidestones but what was
so special about the stones it was more
than just an impressively large Granite
Construction it was the new Ten
Commandments sand blasted in four inch
high letters that RC Christian left to
benefit Humanity maintain Humanity under
500 million In Perpetual balance with
nature God reproduction wisely improving
Fitness and diversity United Humanity
with a living new language real passion
Faith tradition and all things with
tempered reason protect people in
nations with Fair laws and just courts
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
Court Floyd Petty laws and useless
officials balance personal rights with
social duties surprise truth beauty love
seeking harmony with the infinite be not
a cancer on the earth leave room for
nature leave room for nature at first
glance some of these Commandments seem
fairly innocent and maybe even Shea but
when you take a closer look the guides
are unsettling some have claimed that
the Georgia Guidestones are instructions
for a new world order an open call for
eugenics genocide and a one world
government but we're told this is all
conspiracy theory that there's no
evidence to support these claims but
there's evidence oh yeah plenty of it
at first glance the 10 rules in the
Georgia guidestone sounded like a Cheesy
New Age bumper sticker but if you read
them carefully they're disturbing let's
start with the first one maintain
Humanity under 500 million In Perpetual
balance with nature the curb population
is just under 8 billion people to
achieve the guidestone's ideal
population means that roughly 94 percent
of people on Earth would need to be
eradicated and there are many people and
think tanks that support this on this
channel we've covered the club of Rome
that defines itself as a non-profit
informal organization of intellectuals
and Business Leaders whose goal is a
critical discussion of pressing Global
issues fine but what the club of Rome
doesn't advertise so openly is that it
was created in 1968 by the morgenthau
group during a secret meeting at
rockefeller's private estate Bellagio oh
here we go in August 1980 just a few
months after the Guidestones went up
Howard Odom a member of the club of Rome
said it's necessary that the U.S cut its
population by two-thirds within the next
50 years he didn't mention how this
should be accomplished but there are
theories you I love theories I know you
do but it does mean if you want the same
standard living you're going to have to
cut our population in the U.S for
example certainly two one fourth that we
have so many wasteful things that won't
be hard you said well be hard to cut the
population by one-fourth it just takes
one generation to get a population down
if nobody bred for one generation
oh
you've probably heard of the Bilderberg
Group it was formed in 1954 as a way to
prevent Another World War that's what
they say publicly so why are Bilderberg
meetings so secret secrecy has created
all kinds of conspiracy theories scale
of theories I know you do one of these
is that the Bilderberg Group believes
that the current population growth is
not sustainable allegedly one way the
Bilderberg Group would try to reduce
human population is by causing pandemics
oh no the theory also says the
Bilderberg Group will keep their true
plan Secret by consolidating all media
to a handful of Mega companies and then
use governments to work with these media
companies on censoring any ideas that go
against the group's wishes oh that's not
a theory that's true well of course it's
true just look at Twitter both Trump and
Biden aggressively pressure Twitter into
censoring any information that went
against their agendas but whether the
Bilderberg Group is behind this or not
is unknown and known only if you're a
sheep and guess who writes the foreign
policy for the Bilderberg Group clever
realm the club of Rome now it's been
alleged that the club of Rome supports
massive depopulation using any means
necessary but didn't we fight World War
II over these ideas well funny you
should mention that the founder of the
Bilderberg Group was Prince Bernard at
the beginning of World War II he was a
Nazi SS officer of course he was now to
be fair after Germany conquered France
Prince Bernard switched sides and fought
for the Allies oh so that makes him okay
hey I'm just given both sides of a story
but many people say that all of this is
nothing but conspiracy theory but the
Georgia Guidestones don't want to reduce
the current population but instead our
instructions for how to rebuild Society
after a cataclysmic world event
okay let's say that's true how should
the remaining survivors maintain control
of the population and who decides the
second guidestone rule addresses this
guide reproduction wisely improving
Fitness and diversity RC Christian wrote
a book entitled Common Sense renewed
which he sent to each member of Congress
in 1986 among a myriad of statements
Christian wrote it is vitally important
that each national government have a
considered population policy the need is
urgent and should take precedence over
other problems even those of National
Defense okay so he wants the government
in charge so what kind of people should
the government allow to have children
responsible parenting will consider both
genetic and environmental factors we
must seek to produce healthy children
and then to mold their characters and to
develop their potentials as socially
worthwhile adults who will in turn carry
the process indefinitely into the future
we have a grave duty to use all
available knowledge in perfecting the
forces which guide our procreation it is
within our power to leave behind us a
new generation of humanity slightly
Superior to our own in intellectual
physical and social capabilities
oh yeah he's a
he's a few people who want big families
generations of single child families
will make possible dramatic improvements
irresponsible child-bearing must be
discouraged by legal and social
pressures allowing only worthy people to
reproduce to create a generation of
genetically Superior children that's
called Eugenics oh so that's frowned
upon it it is it's what the Nazis did or
tried to do it's also a war crime but
maybe not a crime at all in the New
World Order the Rockefeller that helped
create the club of Rome is the same guy
who founded the population Council in
1954. the population Council supported
and still supports research in birth
control and early birth termination
specifically in those people with
undesirable genetics how do we know
Rockefeller said so modern civilization
had reduced the operation of natural
selection by Saving more weak lives and
enabling them to reproduce resulting in
a downward Trend in genetic quality an
organization that needed to be created
that would be devoted to the reduction
of fertility of weaker individuals with
undesirable genetics one of the members
of the population Council as recently as
2020 has been accused of supporting
forced sterilization the council is
still active today it operates its
programs in Africa Asia Latin America
and the Middle East notice that North
America and Europe are not on that list
now maybe it's just a coincidence but
the council is focused on countries that
are primarily non-white the population
Council takes in millions upon millions
of dollars every year and the biggest
contributor United States government
improve Public Health has caused the
world's infant mortality rate to decline
by 60 percent over the last 40 years
in the same period the world's average
life expectancy has increased from 46
years in 1950s to 63 years today
the negative impact of population growth
on all of our planetary ecosystems is
becoming appallingly evident
guide number one was population control
guide number two was breeding a superior
Society through Eugenics guide numbers
three and five are just as chilling
unite Humanity with a living new
language let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
Court uniting the world under a new
single language and rectifying all
disagreements in a world Court these are
key to creating the New World Order and
local ministers pointed out that the
Book of Revelations warned of a common
tongue and a one world government as the
accomplishments of the Antichrist and
guide number four rule passion Faith
tradition and all things with tempered
reason this also upset Christians who
believe in faith above all after all
it's the first commandment God said you
shall have no other gods before me God
wasn't down with tempered reason these
seemingly anti-faith messages made the
Georgia Guidestones a location for
alleged satanic worship Witchcraft and
Pagan rituals Albertson locals have
reported seeing lights near the
Guidestones they've heard chanting they
found melted candles on the Capstone now
no humans were sacrificed there but I
can't say the same for a few chickens
who had a less than amazing visit to the
Georgia Guidestones now other theories
suggest that Stones were built on Native
Hopi lands and that the Hopi have a
prophecy regarding the ushering in of a
new world other theories say that the
stones are set on Ley lines along with
other icons like the Great Pyramids
Great Wall of China and Stonehenge and
that's not even mentioning the proposed
connections to the order of the rosy
cross the rosicrucians who deserve their
own episode but the biggest mystery of
all was who funded this project what
would take 35 years but we finally have
our answer
the planet
can support
something like a billion people
if you want more Liberty
and more consumption you have to have
fewer people and
conversely you can have more people I
mean we could even have
eight or nine billion probably if we
have a very strong dictatorship which is
smart it's unfortunately you never have
Smart dictatorships they're always
stupid so but if you had a smart
dictatorship and a low standard of
living you could have a but but we want
to have freedom and we want to have a
high sense so we're going to have a
billion people and we're now at seven so
we have to get back down I hope that
this can be slow relatively slow
and that it can be done in a way which
is relatively equal uh you know so that
people share uh the experience and they
don't have a few Rich you know trying to
force everybody else to to deal with it
so those are my hopes I mean these are
pretty
pessimistic folks you know but I mean
that's
that's what lies ahead
over the years internet detectives have
had many theories about the true
identity of RC Christian businessman and
founder of CNN Ted Turner was a leading
candidate he had the money his
foundation was created to protect the
environment and he specifically said
that the greatest threat to civilization
is overpopulation but Ted Turner can't
be RC Christian why not because Ted
Turner is still alive all these
Christian guys dead yep Wyatt Martin the
bank owner who knew Christians true
identity kept Christian's identity a
secret Christian and Martin exchanged
letters at least twice a year until
Christian's death the letters were never
sent from the same place nor were the
funds transferred from the same place
twice Martin passed away in December
2021 but he did drop some Clues along
the way whether he meant to or not
Martin confirmed that Christian died
after the year 2000 he mentioned that
Christian had a daughter and that he was
in basic training in Georgia before
being deployed in World War II Martin
said that Christian was from the Midwest
and at some point he worked in
construction yeah is that enough
almost what sealed the deal was
something that took place in 2005 when a
documentary crew was filming dark clouds
over Elberton Wyatt Martin had recently
suffered a stroke and was in pretty bad
Health the film crew pressured him to
show them the letters that he received
from RC Christian over the years Martin
was reluctant but eventually agreed
though he was careful to hide his
postmarks on the envelopes when he was
showing them the camera but the
cameraman was able to grab a close-up
shot of an envelope in the box which had
a return address he kind of a dick moved
to take advantage of the old time man I
agree but even though we mean it like
the way we came about this information
it doesn't change the fact that we have
it so using this information people on
the internet did what they do best oh
leave nasty comments on videos about how
you content sex no they track down the
address
the letters came from Dr Herbert hinsey
Kirsten a surgeon from Fort Dodge Iowa
Kirsten is an old German Forum of the
name Christian he died after 2000 like
the old timer said Kirsten died in 2005.
now according to Kirsten's obituary he
served in World War II he was a
conservationalist Who Loved nature and
trees he was a naturalist who was very
involved in environmental and world
population issues Bingo this is the guy
Hurston also worked in construction when
he was younger and he had two sons and
two daughters the guy who wants to limit
people to one Rugrat had four of them
yep bill for thee but not for Mia you
sure this guy wasn't in Congress well
I'm sure but he did have a couple of
famous friends one of them was William
Shockley Shockley was a physicist and
inventor he actually won the Nobel Prize
for physics in 1956. yeah sounds like a
good guy well he was also known for
being a racist who supported Eugenics
well I take back what I said about
Shockley argued that less intelligent
people were having too many children and
reducing the average intelligence of the
population he also believed that some
races were more intelligent than others
clearly Dr Kirsten AKA RC Christian
shared similar views though the Georgia
Guidestones aren't specifically racist
we know that Dr Kirsten was a supporter
of David Duke former Grand wizard of the
KKK if maybe it's not so bad that
somebody blew these things up eh well
destruction of the Guidestones is the
final piece of the story or is it
foreign
on July 6 2022 just after 4 a.m CCTV
picked up an individual running to the
stones carrying something seconds later
there's an explosion and one of the four
monoliths is destroyed less than a
minute later a car is captured on camera
leaving the scene what's strange is
within hours heavy equipment was brought
in to clean up the site shouldn't this
have been a crime scene for longer than
a few hours ATF was on the scene almost
immediately weren't they curious about
what kind of explosive was used what
components it was made of what kind of
trigger device was employed modern
forensics can give us all kinds of
information but all the evidence was
quickly removed the Guidestones were in
a remote location there's only one Road
in or out there's no footage of this
vehicle once it leaves the area it's the
middle of the night in Northern Georgia
it would be one of the only cars on the
road but we don't have any new
information
well I'm not saying that I'm just saying
there are questions that can now never
be answered because the site along with
any evidence was cleaned up on almost
immediately it's very possible this was
carried out by someone who is very
anti-government or maybe someone who is
just anti-hypocrisy all these people
that want us to live by the one child
policy seem to have plenty of children
Rockefeller had six kids William
Shockley had three RC Christian AKA Dr
Kirsten had four but the rest of us are
only allowed to have one child and only
if we're genetically fit who decides
who's genetically fit well they do they
want to limit the population of the
Earth without acknowledging that it was
the rapid growth and advancement of the
human race that allowed them to amass
ridiculous wealth now that they have
theirs they want to limit what we can
have these same people are the ones who
scream about climate change fossil fuels
pollution they want to decide who could
own what kinds of vehicles and how much
energy you can use to warm your house in
the winter but how did JD Rockefeller
make his money oil Aurelio Pache who
founded the club of Rome he made his
fortune working for Fiat a huge company
that makes cars trains planes tractors
and military equipment when they were
making their families rich and Powerful
the climate wasn't as big a concern but
now it is all the problems facing our
planet can be solved like they've always
been solved for our Collective
Innovation and cooperation all of us but
the elites don't want cooperation they
want control they don't see any problem
with this they have Superior genetics
they don't believe we're intelligent
enough to make these decisions for
ourselves so they'll make those
decisions for us it's very possible and
maybe even likely that whoever destroyed
the Georgia Guidestones was aware of
this hypocrisy now look I don't condone
the destruction of property I know why
some monuments and statues are offensive
to some people but those people don't
have the right to just decide on their
own to tear them down people should vote
on what statues go up and what monuments
come down anything else is vandalism and
vigilantism I don't like the fact that
someone took the law into their own
hands and destroyed the Georgia
guidestone now I hope he's found and
sent to prison for what he's done but
now that they're gone I say good
riddance
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
subscribe like comment share I know
everyone tells you to do that stuff but
it really helps our channels and like
most topics we cover on this channel
today's topic is recommended by you so
if there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to thewifiles.com
tips a special thanks to our patrons who
make the Wi-Fi as possible I'm
constantly amazed by your generosity and
if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a patreon member or
grab something from the Wi-Fi store by
wearing a hecka fish t-shirt you could
prove to the world that you have
Superior genetics I can't argue with
that that's gonna do it until next time
be safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
thank you